I cannot wait for this to be over so I
can go back to being a normal Anonymous
lawyer
who also happens to be a Hulk what are
you talking about Jen the genie is out
of the bottle girl you are a story now
well you know there are many female
perspectives
um baked into this story there were
certain things that felt very Universal
to all the women involved in production
there is so much information to be
gleaned from the female perspective in
it and from the way that Jen experiences
for hulkness I think we can relate to
that in in so many ways it's very real
which was always the goal like it makes
me so happy there are so many moments in
the show where they immediately thought
oh a woman definitely wrote this now
tell us what's it like being a female
lawyer
twice the work half the recognition and
you're constantly being asked what it's
like being a female lawyer you know we
actually get into her conflict with
people uh not necessarily even
responding to her as Jen but only to her
as she all life would be so much easier
if I was just Jen I think you're in a
unique position to do some real good
well our writer's room was majority
women and so having so many different
women
um all share their life experiences and
sharing the kind of issues that they
deal with stories from their past
they've experienced like all of that
brings this totality of the woman
experience it's funny because that
walking in the dark alley and then
having that moment of realization where
you can switch oh wait
[Music]
get off me
that was one of the core scenes for me
we wanted this to be super specific
we're definitely not saying anything
broad about everybody but I think people
will relate to it and feel it and be
shocked by certain things and be upset
by certain things and then also be
relieved by Jen grabbing a hold of her
story and saying like no I'd rather do
this actually it's these conversations
you know the conversations between the
writers and Tatiana and we and the men
were included in them too Kevin and Brad
and you know all the creative males
behind it but just having those female
voices to kind of go this is what my
experience is I love it it makes me so
happy it's what I want to see in the MCU
and to be able to do it is an honor and
and a pleasure the message we're sending
is that if you attack harm or harass
innocent people I'm coming for you do
you mean in the courtroom whereas a
superhero
oh
now tell our viewers who are you wearing
to court today okay
[Music]
foreign